no I'm not doing that I'm curious where
did you say you were from again Pakistan
Pakistan what is there the same problem
with modern women there that we have
here
um I think it's getting there because uh
social media is so globalized so they're
starting to pick up the same morals and
values uh it's not quite there yet it's
still very much men and men and women
are women
um but the ones that live in Britain or
in the US they're totally like the
westerners
um and this might be ignorant but is
this that Muslim yeah okay yeah so are
you cool like with the can you you can
have three wives we can have four wives
um my dad has two wives so yeah
that's so interesting what was that like
I really liked it I mean it's not it
wasn't easy for everybody but
um yeah so like what
um I have a family I have four brothers
and sisters in Pakistan and I've got me
and my five in uh England and um we
didn't know for a quite a bit of our
lives and then we kind of got introduced
later on and so on and so forth but you
didn't know we didn't know wait for a
little while wait how because I think my
mom was trying to Shield us from it
because it's so unfamiliar to her but it
was familiar in my dad's kind of like a
region where he's from and she was kind
of shielding us from it but then we
wanted to introduce and blend the
families out I really like the idea of
having extra siblings and um but my
dad's mainly with us but what I found
hard is how much he just couldn't split
his time equally was so much more close
to us than he was with them so it's
almost a bit difficult to watch how
they've got a completely different
father than we have so where did they
live they live in Pakistan oh and we
live in England oh I didn't I didn't
realize okay absolutely by Coastal yeah
so then when when did that split like
when did you guys move well my dad grew
up in Pakistan had kids everything then
came to England and then met my mum and
then got married and all these things we
say it's because of the passport you
know we don't want to point out here
um but you know so and then he just
started a family with my mum and uh and
that's just her and but he goes back and
forth
we're all like yeah but you were the
second family though yeah so we were
kind of but you kind of were the first
in a way like he spent more time with
you yeah we're the second family but you
get more of the you know you get more
treatment if I'm honest and so not fair
and he's still married
do they do they get jealous my mom does
my mom does um yeah because she's she
came here when she was about 14.
attention she gets such a good life but
she's far more because she came here
when she was 14 so her values are
different whereas the one in um in
Pakistan her values are just accepting
that this is what a lot of men just go
to a different country did she not know
initially she did know
but she just is so jealous regarding it
whereas it just shows you how cultural
it is because the other one because it's
so part of their family and their
culture she's so okay with it but with
my mum because it's not part of her
family and not part of her culture she's
so not okay with it even though she gets
a far better end of the deal so I guess
it's because I'm very possessive and
jealous as well even with my partner and
I think it must be conditioned in me
because I see other cultures and they
actually just get on with it would you
accept it no no I I don't know maybe I
would if it was like if I was the second
one of this Sunday I think the first one
would be really difficult to accept that
yeah
um but yeah no I don't think I would I
oh yeah I don't think I would but you
never you never know God it might test
you differently I saw a comment the
other day
um and I I have no idea if this is true
I just read a comment they said muslim
girls are the new Catholic girls okay
and so like basically saying that
feminism is kind of seeping into that
Community too and you're starting to get
would you say that's true absolutely
because I deal with a lot of clients and
a lot of my um clients are men Muslim
men and the treatment that they get from
their it's it's different because before
it would be like the culture I was
raised it's like my brother gets a
completely different treatment to us so
we cook clean everything and we do
everything for him he doesn't have to do
any of that and we're okay with that
we're totally fine with that but now
we're living in a world where that scene
is so unfair whereas we kind of accept
it because we wouldn't pay for anything
uh but we would do all the chores and we
just accepted that Dynamic but now the
culture is you're getting to a Muslim
man and a Muslim woman raised in the
same home but getting a totally
different experience and getting really
resentful about that so the girls are
seeing that and thinking that's unfair
the men are just used to it and this
building that resentment whereas we just
accepted that's part of our upbringing
so I think it is becoming really angry
feminists now
that's interesting I've only met like
one or two people that had that multiple
ones is it common like it's not is it
coming in like where you guys are from
it's so common my dad can have it but my
mom wouldn't have it yeah
she can but my mom is very Western so
she wouldn't she wouldn't sit for it
yeah oh yeah I wonder then does that
mean jealousy is something we condition
or like no just like it's just you have
to know the wife you marry like some
women will will be okay with that some
of them won't well I think it's like
women we don't want the it's like the
biological reason is we don't want the
resources to go to someone else so
that's like why if a girl catches it
like a guy cheating it's like do you
love her where if a guy catches a girl
cheating like don't guys ask like where
they slept together and all this stuff
like was was he bigger was he I mean I
don't no I've I've never been in that
situation you'd be more okay do you
think women would be more okay with two
wise rather than just a man that
constantly has like what do you think it
would be better for women I mean I think
the two wives would be better but I
think modern women are sideshare I think
modern it's like situation chips and
what's a situationship you're sharing a
guy so earlier when I said what do women
share men is like your family is an
example and your dad is one of the men
that has access to these men these men
out there that can't get one but that
has two families
they provided for both of them yeah both
women don't work yeah so so what's it
what it says again if you can provide
yeah there'll be women out there that
are not going to be bothered because in
reality women are not bothered but they
just have to there's a certain cost for
the what's the word for the submission
what is your submission cause and that's
all it is like there's a there's a and
some of us we can't access some of us
you know we can't we don't have the fun
for that submission and other people do
and so that's why if you're when women
say oh if my man cheated on me as a
million I'll leave him in reality if a
man pulls up in the Lamborghini and then
you discover he does something and you
say I'm going to leave you I didn't see
it
he's literally he's
in your life listen you're gonna walk in
walking betting a girl over and you're
still not gonna see it literally I'm
blind oh yeah this Burkin I'm blind
[Laughter]
Mark do you want to be monogamous yeah
like like so I like there's no point in
being married if I still want to be
outside right because I can just be
outside and I do believe like at some
point as a man it gets boring you're
gonna find it boring you like you want
one woman and all of that stuff and also
if I have a children I just don't want
to be out there like on their mother but
I just like yeah like because if you
leave it long enough then you don't need
to be outside normal but if you want to
be outside be outside like you don't
have to if you don't want to be married
don't be married just be in a
relationship and this I think today
there's so many different types of
relationships you can have Pearl I don't
think anyone has to kind of just have
you can basically have whatever you want
like you just have to find the people
for it right like like going to the
communities this whole poly hashtags
nowadays you know what I mean like if
you want that don't go get a girl which
you're gonna destroy your whole life and
then ruin how she thinks about men it's
just fine as many of you know I was just
banned on Tic Tac and we are demonetized
on a daily basis on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible